let's start off with Ukraine Russia when
it first got started
um you know you were one of the ones
that said this is going to be done in no
time it's almost done it's going to be
done it's going to be done in a week
it's going to be done in a month it's
going to be done in two months it's
gonna so a lot a lot of people felt the
same way as you but you were one of the
main spokespeople that kept saying this
is going to get done why is it still
going on today and it's been as long as
it's been no I think that's an important
question and it surprised me as well as
lots of other people uh by the
by the way the Russians went into
Ukraine their their initial operation
was very different from what anybody
anticipated
and I think President Putin went in with
the following objectives remember he's
been talking for at least 15 years about
his opposition to the movement of NATO
to his borders
he's made it very clear that he regarded
it as a threat one of the reasons he
moved into Crimea was that he saw that
becoming a NATO Naval base principally
for the U.S Navy obviously in the Black
Sea
so he moved on that first and then said
look I it's got to stop well what
happened of course is you know is we had
the coup in Kiev where now the
ukrainians call it Keith
and as a result we installed a
government that was prepared to do
essentially whatever we wanted them to
do and we poured billions of dollars in
very early to build up an enormous
Ukrainian military force whose sole
objective was to attack Russia
and it wasn't very long before Putin
concluded that if I don't act soon I'll
have missiles sitting on my border that
will be able to reach my Nuclear
deterrent in no time and Rob Russia of
any sort of security at all
so he decides to go in but I think he
thought at the beginning and this was a
false assumption that he would have
someone to negotiate with
so he said I'm going to go in really
initially with only about 90 000 troops
organized into small contingents he gave
strict orders that they were to avoid
collateral damage at all costs didn't
want to kill anybody he knew he was
moving into an area which was largely
Russian anyway
but he also didn't want to kill
Ukrainian forces at that point he said I
want to demilitarize the place but he
said I don't want unnecessary casualties
on the Ukrainian side and remember from
his vantage point
these were also Slavic cousins Brothers
whatever you want to call them and the
Russians felt that way I think initially
and so he moves in with this very small
Force he encounters a lot of resistance
I think the resistance is exaggerated in
the sense that the Russians have never
taken heavy casualties but nevertheless
he encountered a great deal of
resistance but most important when he
met with people for negotiations he
discovered there there's no willingness
to reach an agreement because Washington
principally is in charge
Washington doesn't want an agreement I
mean he can read the tea leaves and the
tea leaves are very clear this is
Washington's opportunity to quote
unquote bleed Russia
in addition to bleeding Russia once
we've bled it we're going to see Putin
and his regime removed and ultimately
then we'll think about what we want to
do with Russia to include stripping it
of resources breaking it up into smaller
parts whatever
this of course was a horror story that
he had not really believed in and he
found out gee I was wrong and so by the
summer he has a meeting with all the
senior officers and they say look we we
wanted to go in hard you told us to go
in soft we wanted more troops you said
no now we're in the middle of something
we're not going to end this conclusively
unless we build a larger and more
decisive force with the right
capabilities and so
you had this change in strategy that
says we will consolidate control over
what we've got which is about 20 to 22
percent of the territory where most of
the Russians but not all lived where
most of the resources are too by the way
and we will run essentially an economy
of force Mission our strategy is to
build an unbreakable Fort and then let
the ukrainians expend themselves against
it and then when we're ready we'll take
the offensive and that's effectively
what's happened and the ukrainians have
expended themselves they are now at a
point where I would say there's
practically nothing left anybody who was
really trained to do much is dead or
wounded
it depends on which source you want to
trust but it runs from 250 000 dead up
to 300 000 dead to 350 000 dead on the
Ukrainian side and that's military force
not yeah that's just that's just the
soldiers that's just soldiers now I
don't know how many civilians have been
killed and I'm very very suspicious of
that because
despite the change in strategy that
resulted he has always been unwilling to
kill quote unquote innocence so if he
strikes something or you see a President
Putin yeah so if you see a strike going
somewhere as we did quite recently the
objective was to kill Frankly Speaking
foreign forces that were bulleted in the
Hotel this included U.S UK and others
because he's been warning everybody in
NATO get out
if you don't get out you're going to be
at risk and then of course next to it I
guess was a school or something and so
immediately the ukrainians say see the
Russians are killing people in schools
you know we went through this repeatedly
where the ukrainians would set up uh gun
positions inside hospitals schools malls
and once that happened the Russians had
no choice but to destroy those gun
positions which meant that they were
inevitably attacking what were formerly
only civilian targets I mean this is not
new we've been through this in the
Middle East we've experienced something
similar
so the bottom line is that now we're at
a point where the ukrainians really have
expended virtually everything they've
got
they're now talking about mounting one
last
counter-offensive I don't know how
they're going to do it whatever they do
it won't succeed
they have no chance of breaking through
Russian defenses in the meantime I think
we've had a certain amount of unrest in
the senior ranks of the Russian military
because a lot of the senior officers
want to attack and end this war
and they're very concerned about a lot
of what senior officials General
officers in the in the Russian army the
senior generals so so then there's a
misalignment between Putin and his
leaders well I don't know if I'd call it
a misalignment as much as Putin is still
reluctant to take decisive action to end
the war quickly because he's concerned
about our predisposition to intervene
the great fear from the beginning has
always been that once it became clear
that the Ukrainian position was hopeless
there would be pressure in Washington to
intervene to rescue what's left
we almost have to protect our 150
billion dollar investment it's almost a
if you think about it it's like hedging
if that does happen hey we're so in it
now that we said once we're not going to
send them tanks if we do it's going to
be this now we're talking you know
planes and all this stuff we almost have
to defend Ukraine now well I I don't
think so but uh I'm sorry from the
bidens administration yeah well your
argument actually uh Probably sounds
more like how we got ourselves into the
first world war but the bottom line is
with with this crowd right now they've
expended enormous sums of money
so I'm sure there's pressure from
BlackRock and Raytheon and others
somebody told me the other day there are
only three branches of government in the
United States now one is Blackrock one
is Raytheon and the other is the
Pharmaceuticals so there's some there's
some Tragic Truth to that since the hill
is a basically owned by donors and we
have government by donors the American
people really don't have much of a voice
and they don't know much about it so
they don't say much about it
but the truth is right now the
ukrainians are are on the on the ropes
there's no doubt about it and there's
this discussion I think behind the
scenes do we just move now and end this
thing decisively because they can
or do we wait some more and let the
ukrainians expend some more time and
effort and now you have discussions in
the west about a joint polish Lithuanian
intervention into Western Ukraine and
that's exactly the sort of thing that
the Russians have been concerned about
and that could never happen without us
without us authorizing it supporting it
and encouraging it and Putin knows that
so we're at a kind of crossroads right
now in terms of what's next and the
Russians have to make a decision well
there's there's a lot there I'm sorry
Tom there's a lot there uh that we
covered a few things so
from a strategy standpoint okay you know
the world when they think about who
Putin is you know former KGB this guy is
going to be a shrewd guy he's going to
be 15 steps ahead or he's going to
identify his next 5 10 15 moves so
you're going to sit there and say if we
do this that guy's gonna do this if we
do this or we're going to push NATO to
want to move quicker to support them if
we do this maybe it's going to be easier
to take over a part of Ukraine that we
want under Biden not Trump because it's
I'm I'm picturing him as a guy that sat
there with his generals looking at every
single possibility that could happen
how did he miss the ball on hey let's go
soft on this it's going to be fine
they're going to cave in we're going to
get him in no time his military guys say
no let's go hard that's a big
miscalculation there on his end isn't it
well I think President Putin you
mentioned his KGB background one of the
things that people do not understand
about the KGB is that the individuals
that served in it were practically the
only people in the Soviet Union that
were allowed to travel beyond the
borders of the Soviet Union
that meant that they could travel in the
west Bhutan was very familiar with the
West particularly with Germany and by
the way he likes Germans speaks pretty
pretty good German
because I've listened to him in his
interviews so from his standpoint he saw
a West that he thought they could work
with they could deal with and he's
always been criticized inside Russia for
taking that position
because I would say the mainstream
Russian position is you can't do
business with the West the West is our
implacable enemy that will never change
we are Russians we are not part of
Europe we are not part of the West I
think Putin took a different position I
think he thought that Russia should be
part of the larger European concert and
should have a role in the west well he
turns out his critics were right and he
was wrong now he's still a very popular
leader because he has improved the
standards of living Prosperity he's
restored a lot of Russian national pride
and dignity I think his latest poll
unofficial poll that we get out of out
of Russia puts him at about 89 percent
approval whereas Biden is at about 30
percent
so I think uh Putin is very secure in
that sense now but he has always
struggled with his idea of how far do I
want to push it because Putin is is a
smart man he says when this is over
we want to live
with the Europeans and we want to live
with the United States we never thought
about that during the second world war
there were some people who did because
we did enormous damage to Japan enormous
damage to Germany which is one of the
reasons we had to stay there for 50
years and there were a few voices admire
Leahy who was effectively the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs at the time for
Roosevelt brought in the generals and
said look you're doing terrible things
to these people we want to be able to
live with the Germans and the Japanese
when this is over
well we didn't pay too much attention to
that but Putin is taking a different
position and he has also made it very
clear that this is Russia this is not
the Soviet Union and the Russian
military contrary to what the ukrainians
have been claiming have not committed
atrocities all over the place they have
not murdered and raped and pillaged in
other words this is not Stalin's Force
his slave Army of 1944 and 45. Putin's
made that very clear he still wants to
get along quote unquote he would he
wants to avoid a direct war with the
United States and with NATO
that drives much of his behavior but as
I said now he's at a point where he's
got to make some decisions
and that is what do we do do we continue
to move slowly and deliberately and
watch as the polls and lithuanians
presumably backed by the United States
intervene in Western Ukraine
is that what we do or do we act because
what he doesn't want is whatever is
remains of Ukraine when this is over he
once that to be neutral he doesn't want
it to be militarized he doesn't want it
to be a platform for attack against
Russia he views Ukraine the same way we
viewed Cuba in 1963. we don't want it to
be a platform for attack against us we
still don't
and that's his position now can he
achieve that if he stands by and allows
the polls the lithuanians or anybody
else even the U.S forces to move into
Western Ukraine I think the answer is no
Colonel is the position you just
described very eloquently on uh
President Putin is that the resolved
view that is in front of President Biden
is that where the Joint Chiefs are or
are they taking a different View
what I do know is that the senior
officers in the Army in the Pentagon I
can't speak for the other services but
certainly the Army had made it very
clear
that we are in no position to wage
conventional war against the Russians
and they're are they presenting what you
just presented as Putin's attitude and
position with that I I doubt it simply
because if you try to present that
position to the people who are really
running the government they are so full
of hatred and animosity and antipathy
for Moscow and what it represents to
them
that no one will listen
so they're I think they're they're they
have what we call ideological blinders
on
so is that why there is so much
willingness if that is a prevailing view
that's being propagated not only to the
president's daily
you know threat report I assume and to
the president himself then is it any
surprise to you that senators or green
lighting billions of dollars for Ukraine
because it's to defeat this evil not to
not to go Middle East on you but to
defeat this evil Satan that is the old
USSR Russia well remember part of the
problem here is of Putin's own making at
the beginning because of the way he went
in it conveyed to the West this notion
of see the Russians aren't serious
they're weak
they're weak they don't know what
they're doing and then we flooded the
Airways with all of this propaganda
about the Russians are stupid and they
describe the Russians exactly the way
the Germans described the Soviets during
World War II which of course was
nonsense I mean I I was in graduate
school and Soviet East European studies
so I'm very familiar with it and they
literally lifted phrases and things out
of books that had been written about the
Soviet Army in the end of the second
world war and they were hurling this
crap at the Russians and and everybody
in the west of course was eager to
believe it remember we have the Cold War
behind us so it's not very hard to say
you know the Russians are really bad
sure oh yeah yeah right they they were
bad a few years ago so they must be bad
again that that's part of the problem
but Putin went in he was he was too easy
and it looked as though he was weak well
now everything is turned around you've
got about 750 000 troops focused on the
western military District in Russia in
other words the Western theater
about 350 000 in the south
now where are the other four hundred
thousand well some of them are tied up
in logistical support infrastructure
some of them are in missile uh rocket
artillery batteries some of them are up
in build Russia some of them are just in
Western Russia
the the point is that this is an
enormously powerful force now with all
the most modern equipment and Technology
I think even the the biggest Skeptics
are shocked and surprised at the
Precision the accuracy and the
responsiveness of Russian missile and
strike assets for people who are
listening who don't have a map in front
of them when you say the Western theater
of Russia you mean the Eastern also
border of Ukraine right there South
human Crimea I'm talking about I'm
talking about in southern Ukraine the
area which is referred to by the
Russians as novel Russia this is this
stretches from basically Odessa all the
way up to karkoff most of that is now
under Russian control with this force of
three quarters of a million yes
so okay so let's go let's go back to uh
thinking
trying to think what Putin was thinking
about so let's go soft instead of going
hard what what's what's the advantages
of going soft so for you as a strategist
to be fair I mean you know when you're
saying you know how you would do it and
what you would do you have a PhD I think
in international
uh uh relations from University of
Virginia if I'm not mistaken so
if if what is the advantage of going
soft are you going soft because you're
thinking that guy's gonna cave okay fine
so let's flip it what is the advantage
of going hard right off the bat where
his soldiers are saying no uh we have to
go strong with these guys to get what
done what's their argument of going hard
instead of going soft
well first let's be clear about the phds
and degrees you know thermometers have
degrees and you know where you stick
those uh I'm not I'm not disparaging my
PhD I'm just being honest there are a
lot of people walking around with
degrees that don't know anything
in fact I would argue that most of them
don't amount to anything they don't
produce anything they're not
practitioners
I focused when I went to graduate school
in military matters because I'm a
professional Soldier and it was my
obligation I saw it since the American
people were funding my education
to focus on Military Affairs and
specifically at that point on the Soviet
Union and to a lesser extent East
Germany and Poland and general Slovakia
those are those are the areas where I
focused now having said that
again it goes back to a set of
assumptions I think that Putin if you go
back and look at his willingness to
negotiate
there was a point during the first three
weeks when the negotiators met that
Putin said I will immediately Embrace a
ceasefire
while these negotiations are on
and they stopped the Russians stopped in
their Tracks Of course people in the
west said well that's because they're
logistically unsustainable and all this
but that wasn't true
he was sending a signal I'm serious I'm
willing to negotiate
and remember that the whole thing
revolved around the Minsk Accords nobody
in the west pays much attention to those
Accords but they were signed by Germany
France we backed them and we promised
that the Russians who live in Ukraine
would be treated as equal citizens equal
before the law along with ukrainians
they would not be pressured to become
Ukrainian as long as they were good
citizens that obeyed the law they could
speak their own language go to their own
schools go to their own church and so
forth
that was a big lie as it turns out and
Angela Merkel who was the German
Chancellor was the first to come out
publicly and say we lied that was just
to buy time for Ukraine to build itself
up into the military power that it has
become
subsequently macron admitted it was a
lie so even after having been lied to
prolifically about all the things that
were important to the Russians uh he
decided I'll call a ceasefire we'll see
how these uh talks progress well the
talks didn't progress and then suddenly
we had this man Boris Johnson who flew
in as as effectively a surrogate for
Biden and said stop
don't give up anything and that was
because solenski had said sure I think
we could live with neutrality actually
made that statement which was the end
goal as far as Putin was concerned we
wanted to be neutral in other words you
have this nice large neutral State the
size of Texas it lies between Russia and
NATO gosh that's a good thing in fact
back in 1999 and 1998 when I was the
director of The Joint operations center
at shape headquarters Supreme
headquarters Allied Powers Europe these
discussions went on and somebody said
well what's ukr where's Ukraine in all
of this and everybody said Ukraine's
mission is to be a nice buffer
you know don't don't fight there don't
go there let them be a nice buffer
between Russia and us I mean that was
widely viewed as a positive thing
well that was thrown out of the window
and instead Boris Johnson says we will
back you to the hilt we will give you
everything that we possibly can your job
is to go out there and fight and will
back you and eventually we will be
victorious the Russians will collapse
Putin will be gone etc etc etc
none of that's happened happy Fourth of
July too we have a special event that's
coming up with Tom Brady Mike Tyson and
we'll get there in Miami Vault
conference it'll be August 30th to
September 2nd this weekend for 4th of
July we're running a special buy one get
one free bring your spouse bring your
business partner bring your running mate
if you haven't yet registered click on
the link below or above get registered
looking forward to spending three days
with you in Miami
[Music]